are you still on cash money yeah i'm
still cash money west but i'm like the
only person on cash when he was
this is true
so what does that tell you
you're kind of carrying the flag i'm the
only person on this label that means
that they're still going to have to put
money and you know me i'm still going to
be doing things like this with you
and all i really need is just because
you'll have records that come out
through e1
so what let me just keep telling them
bro i have the best dlc
i could do whatever i want listen i'm
being honest like
i've seen
the shittiest you have one of the best
situations i've seen
i have to tell you and black
best manager
for the situation because he's
he can muscle [ __ ] like and he got his
he got so many resources because he's
been doing this [ __ ] forever yeah
talk about whack because i think whack
is obviously
more popular than ever
he's um
you know i've known whack for about a
decade now and uh
i always tell everybody a wax one of the
most solid [ __ ] you'll ever
come into but what do you think are like
some of the misconceptions about whack
because i feel like there are a lot of
them out there
uh
why why is 100 like you know
he will make sure you straight if
if you're in his good graces you know
yes it doesn't take much to being as
good gracious just being solid
like
solid like
well i remember the first time i met you
like him and his wife and they're like
yo we're getting in his house we're
getting his credit together like we're
making sure he got okay i'm in the best
position like you know what i'm saying
like
the music is like half the battle for me
right now like i actually got [ __ ] going
but yeah like back to wack he's 100 he's
a great manager um
his personal life was like you know
that's he should be turned up sometimes
that's that's that clubhouse [ __ ] i'm
like yeah that's where he that's where
he does his
his thing so it's like you know i'm we
don't let that get involved but